la parole est à notre collègue bruno
belin pour le groupe l'est républicain
je remercie monsieur le président mes
chers collègues
il était une fois un ministre de
l'éducation nationale qui devant le
sénat le 21 janvier
2021 déclara
aucune classe aucune école ne sera
jamais fermé sans l'accord du maire
face aux trop nombreuses charrette de
fermetures de classes que nous
constatons tous dans nos communes nous
nous disons que le ministre de
l'éducation nationale a bien changé
la situation elle n'a pas changé
nous avons dans ces écoles les élèves de
la génération autotests qui vont
terminer leur troisième année scolaire
dans une situation de grande souffrance
psychologique
voire pour certains en plein décrochage
sur le premier ministre puisque le
ministre n'est pas là quelle est la
stratégie du gouvernement en matière de
carte scolaire notamment en milieu rural
je vous remercie
la parole de la secrétaire d'état en
charge de la jeunesse et de l'engagement
madame l aérés
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs monsieur le sénateur belin
le ministre de l'éducation nationale de
la jeunesse et des sports qu'est-ce qui
l'a dit parce que c'était la volonté du
président de la république qu aucune
école ne ferme dans un territoire rural
qu aucune école ne ferme nulle part sans
l'accord des maires parce que oui
monsieur le sénateur c'est bien en
concertation avec les maires avec les
élus locaux qu'on construit cette carte
scolaire mais également qu'on construit
en réalité notre territoire qu'on le
fait qu'on finalement qu'on
l'accompagnent qu'on le compense
finalement comment on va installer ou
pas des habitations comment on rénove
les centres bourgs et tout cela ça a été
monsieur le sénateur tout cela ça a été
monsieur sénateurs ce qui a été fait
au-delà de ça monsieur le sénateur alors
même qu' il y à une perte de nombre
d'élèves - 78 mille élèves en perte eh
bien il ya 14 1380 postes qui ont été
créés l'encadrement dans l'est dans les
écoles rurales n'a jamais été aussi fort
parce que c'est une volonté une volonté
du président de la république une
volonté mise en oeuvre par ce
gouvernement au delà de l'encadrement
monsieur le sénateur vous avez parlé de
la tra du travail et de la préparation
de la carte scolaire c'est un moment
absolument clé parce qu'il est construit
avec les élus locaux il est construit
dans un dialogue absolument intense est
absolument essentiel monsieur le
sénateur
l'engagement du président de la
république pas une école fermée dans les
territoires ruraux sans l'accord des
élus locaux
monsieur moulin
merci le seul président les élus ruraux
ont le sentiment que l'état ferait tout
pour que la france des campagnes haye de
mal en pis
carburant hors de prix construction et
paix lui interdit communes sont
trésorerie territoire sans téléphonie
médecin parti est maintenant quatre
scolaire sans trajet sans stratégie
c'est une une faute et une erreur c'est
une faute parce que le ministre de
l'éducation nationale ne tient pas son
engagement d'écouter les élus c'est une
erreur parce que la france des campagnes
la france rurale est en train de se
reconstruire grâce à ses élus un tenant
d'une main la fibre en tenant de
l'auteur pour inventer des services en
essayant de sauver des commerces la
modernité c'est la ruralité l'espoir
c'est l'espace alors il est encore temps
de sauver et de revenir sur cette
décision d' en donnant des instructions
pour faire cesser la casse des classes
est sacralisé la ruralité je vous
remercie
merci
[Applaudissements]